Welcome back, ladies and gentlemen!
Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello, hello!
Hi!
Welcome...
I need to enunciate more.
I need to enunciate.
Welcome to...
Lifeline!
Hi, Minto.
Hello!
Nostalgic?
This game?
I haven't played this before.
This is my first time.
Good morning.
Good morning!
Enunciated Minky.
This game will make you question your life choices.
Or my afterlife choices.
I've never played this game before, but if you don't know what this is...
As it says, it is a voice action adventure.
I will be speaking.
I'll be saying blah, blah, blah.
And the game should listen to me.
TGIF Minto!
TGIF!
TGIF.
Hold on, I have something stuck in my throat.
I just had a chicken nugget.
I should have... That is suboptimal conditions to speak.
We can watch the little intro that it does.
Even though I have... Yeah, should.
Should is the key word here, right?
It should.
It should listen to what I have to say.
So, I had this on my schedule like, what, two weeks ago or something?
And then I lost my voice.
So...
Space.
I don't know anything about this game.
I'm gonna die if you don't think of something quick!
She's gonna die if I don't think of something quick!
I cannot talk.
Number two!
Number one!
I'm... I'm practicing.
I need to confess something.
When I was a child, I swore on Club Penguin.
I think everybody swore on Club Penguin.
It's okay.
Wait, I have to yell reload?
Oh gosh.
Wait.
Dodge right?
Oh gosh.
Dodge right!
Reload!
Oh no.
Not sure if you're joining us for the war in four hours.
Oh, the general sales?
Actually, I got a ticket from a friend, so...
Good luck everybody else!
Yeah, good luck!
For the HoloExpo tickets, right?
It's my birthday six minutes ago!
Can I maybe get an MGS themed happy birthday?
Of course!
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
With salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your scars stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
I think you meant it means a lot.
Of course!
It drives me up the freaking wall that you guys donate though to give me this thing happy birthday.
Because it's your birthday.
It doesn't feel very fair.
Sorry though.
The video keeps trying to replay.
Give him a one and a two, Minto!
Yeah, I'll give him the one, two.
One and two.
Respectively.
Maybe two and one sometimes.
We might get a little funky.
Let's play a new game.
New game.
One of the games of all time.
I've been out of my mind excited for this.
Ever since you put on your schedule a few weeks back.
You're going to love Rio.
Square?
Press square button?
That's interesting.
Also, I didn't want to start the game.
So I haven't tested this.
Quite honestly, but I have a contingency plan in case it's like...
In case it's like, oh no, can't work.
Okay, so...
I'm speaking normally.
Wait, explanation for using the analog controller during the tutorial is provided in the initial setting.
Okay.
Hi.
Da.
Circle?
It's not doing anything.
Oh.
Hello.
Not yet.
Okay.
Oh.
Hello.
I see that it's...Oh!
It works!
I just had to let go.
PlayStation.
Yeah!
Lifeline TM.
Okay.
Great!
Why was hello excellent?
My score.
Aki!
Thank you for the 10 Ginten!
Thank you!
Alright.
I'm gonna order her around.
Oh, I cannot talk again.
Get on all floors.
I feel like I just got sprayed with a spray bottle.
Bad.
Walk.
Excellent.
Oh yeah.
RUN!
Okay, but this is like...If I'm telling her to run, it's imperative.
I mean, is it not?
Would it not be in a severe situation?
I believe.
Kevin, welcome to Mambo Ship!
Somebody's gonna clip that.
I've already...I've lost every amount of dignity.
It doesn't matter where anybody is clipped now.
Run.
Stop!
What?
Why?
Stop!
No!
What?
Stop!
Okay.
Great pronunciation.
Nice voice.
Okay.
Go to the table.
Great.
Let's check it out.
So like, if I say...
Go to the...
The bottle.
Go to the bottle.
In this case, saying green bottle is better for recognition than saying bottle.
Wow.
Bad.
Disarray.
Welcome to Mambo Ship.
Thank you.
Go to the phallic shape.
What if I say something like that?
What if I don't even know what it is?
Once the name is revealed, you can give more specific instructions.
Alright.
Check the wine.
Oh, she's checking it out.
Bad.
Seems like nothing is unusual about the wine.
When you find anything remotely curious, it's best to check the item carefully.
Additionally, certain objects can be combined with various verbs when you give instructions.
Drink the wine!
Get the wine!
Congratulations on your new...
Bad.
Okay.
Go back.
Nice.
I'm pro at this.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
When giving vocal commands, the best technique is to combine nouns and verbs.
Let's remember some battle commands.
Next, when the enemy is detected, we will automatically move to defeat it.
Carefully observe the enemy while giving commands.
Let's try making an actual attack.
Excellent!
Move left!
Shoot!
Dodge!
Good!
Sir Noodles, welcome to Mambo Ship!
Dodge and shoot!
Oh my god.
What is that?
Flee and recover!
Flee!
Shoot, shoot, shoot!
When multiple enemies appear, targeting can be prioritized with number 1, number 2, etc.
Number 2!
Number 1.
What!?
Oh my gosh.
This is literally saying that I'm good at English.
Viewers are commenting on the Scottish accent.
I'm trying to say words in her accent.
Should I have an accent for this whole stream?
The relevant portion of the enemy appears at the bottom of the screen.
What do you mean by the relevant proportion?
I don't think this thing has...
I think it's just a blob.
It doesn't have any of those features.
I think.
Head, shoot, reload!
Good!
Oh my goodness, okay.
Stomach!
Stomach What?
Stomach Okay Bad Okay
Okay, okay, okay
I used to be an English teacher.
This is perfect!
Yeah!
Now we begin our tale.
Really?
Yeah, I was an English teacher for Japanese students.
In 16th century Europe, there lived a physician by the name of Perikelsis.
Not only was he one of the era's finest medical minds, he also made contributions in alchemy, astrology, astronomy, and mysticism.
Probably.
When he was in his thirties, he was said to have incredible healing abilities.
That prompted him to adopt the name of Perikelsis, superseding Kelsis, the famed doctor of ancient times.
What is this lore?
In his later years, he is said to have gone on a journey of healing, visiting the terminally ill, and curing them with miraculous powers.
Okay, what else would he do after curing them?
Just stay there?
Konami Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Lifeline Nice
Earth Space December 24th, 2029?
No way, that's in just a couple years!
Oh my gosh, we'll be able to speak in just four years!
Oh my gosh.
Got off work just in time.
Let's go!
Wait, crash out.
What's up?
Space Today I learned... Oh no!
That doesn't seem too good.
I don't think in 2029 we can breathe in space.
Minto playing peek.
Thank you!
I learned that... You know the wild thornberries?
I did not know that the dad was Tim Curry.
I had no idea.
I learned that today.
Uh-oh
Smashing.
Is this the monitor room?
Yeah.
The station has been critically damaged.
Manual operation limited.
Monitor room has been locked down.
Operators in room should await rescue.
Show me your kittens.
Thanks for the gift!
A wound!
Oh my gosh Surveillance camera recording concluded.
Now we are playing recording from the restaurant.
Fancy.
Say words that rhyme with heal.
Thanks for the hint!
This is the opening party.
A little while ago.
Thanks for the birthday party.
Shut up Murphy.
Oh my gosh.
That's me and Naomi.
Where is this Metal Gear?
We were lucky to be invited to the space station hotel.
No thank you.
Naomi.
Sorry.
She looks like Tifa.
Kind of.
This is so fancy.
Wow.
They are playing the jazz.
That's not how you hold a microphone maybe.
I think.
The whole room shook violently and something crashed the party.
It was me.
They started eating guests.
I'm a bit of a party crasher.
We ran away.
Naomi!
No, that is not a solid snake.
If we just play this whole game as if we are a snake, that would be so funny.
And then, I passed out.
I can't believe we are spending Christmas in space.
Thank you.
I can't believe we are spending Christmas separated from my beloved girlfriend.
Oh my gosh.
We were probably going to propose, weren't we?
No.
I can't believe we are spending Christmas in space.
I have a question though.
Is there actually no subtitles in this game?
There is a call from the security room.
Communication link will be open.
None?
OK.
I'll just keep the volume a little bit higher than usual.
Come in, please.
Hello.
Oh, I cannot talk.
Sorry.
Finally, my efforts pay off.
Scrapdog and the membership!
Is the comm link still live?
Operator, can you say something?
Hey girl!
What's with the casual attitude?
You don't sound like the regular guy.
Anyway, it doesn't matter who you are now.
Listen, will you please undo the lock?
How do the guests taste?
They taste chewy and full of money.
The immediate meat gear connection.
Let's call it meat gear.
Opened and...oh wait.
OK, understood.
Please hurry.
Sorry, I tried to say panel and door at the same time.
Hold on.
Unlock panel.
Open door panel.
Operate door panel.
Door panel open.
If you hard, then you hard.
Disengage lock.
Press button.
What I want you to do is open the lock on this door.
Alright?
I'm trying!
I did it!
Please disengage the lock on this door.
The lock is open.
Saved at last.
A real head case security guard locked me up in there for over an hour.
Jeez.
How's the volume by the way guys?
Sorry if it gets really loud.
I had to turn it up quite a bit.
It's good?
OK.
Nice behind.
Oh, cannot talk.
What are you getting?
A snack?
OK.
What about in there?
Alright.
She does not move with any matter of urgency or purpose, does she?
OK.
She's taking her time.
Open box.
OK.
Locker.
I hardly even know her.
OK.
The locker is locked.
Open.
It's weird.
I have to press square for it.
She's trying.
She's really cute.
You became the codec.
Right!
Oh my gosh!
No way!
What?
She was going to get a gun?
Look, I'm in a bit of a hurry.
Just wait there to be rescued.
If we're lucky, we'll see each other soon.
Until then.
What?
Ma'am?
You're going to rescue me?
Oh my god!
Are you OK?
Oh, nevermind.
Get up!
I think I killed her.
I think...
You said you could handle yourself.
OK.
Battle time baby.
Shoot!
Middle eye!
Dodge!
Shoot!
OK.
Where are you going?
Nice!
Mouth!
Shoot!
Right eye!
Left eye!
Shoot!
She's doing it.
Shoot again!
Alright.
Dodge!
Where are you going?
Shoot!
Mouth.
Yeah, that works.
Middle eye!
Shoot!
Right eye!
Left eye!
Shoot!
Body!
No.
Oh wait.
Run!
Oh my god.
Wait.
Run and reload!
That works.
Body!
Shoot!
Run!
Oh my god.
No, is she going to die?
Run away!
OK.
Nice, nice, nice.
She listened.
Body!
Shoot!
Oh wait.
Red eye!
Shoot!
There's a red eye?
Oh, I did it!
Oh my gosh, I'm a genius.
Yeah!
Gaming.
I thought you knew what you were supposed to do.
Yeah.
Oh.
Me?
My girlfriend.
Mint.
Solid Snake.
Minky.
Say David Hater.
Non-stop Nemi Nightmare.
And she's...
You lost her?
Well, no wonder.
And all that commotion.
Me?
I don't even remember how I managed to get out of the restaurant.
It's my girlfriend everybody!
She may be in need of help somewhere.
Listen, can I ask for your help?
Before escaping from the Station Hotel, there's something that I have to find.
I would never say that Naomi is my girlfriend.
Can you help me out as an Operator?
Like the way you did before?
In return, I'll find you Naomi along the way.
My Naomi.
So, it's a deal?
I can count on your help?
Let me talk.
You can call me Rio.
Okay, glad to meet you Operator.
That makes you Otacon.
No!
Are you ready?
Let's go baby girl.
I guess there's no need for formal introductions.
Rio...
Well, that's fine.
I won't fail in my search.
Alright, let's go save the day.
Listen Operator.
Let's choose a password for ourselves.
You don't know very much about this hotel, do you?
I don't, no.
I bet there's lots of things that'll confuse you while we're searching.
Like what should we be doing for instance?
I have no idea.
So, in a situation like that...
Let's see...
Say consultation.
If you say that, I'll explain things to you.
Okay?
Is that...
Try saying the word.
Is that a password?
Consultation.
Say it please.
Yep, a consultation.
She looks so happy!
Sick.
Yep.
Good job, Minto.
Thank you.
Girl, you need some like...
You need to follow your own life path, you know?
For example, in this room...
There are places like the lockers and the table.
You know how you can display maps in the monitor room?
Direct me where you want to go by the name on the map.
Do you understand?
I think...
Maybe...
It's written on the map.
Use the proper name, okay?
Go to the lockers.
Exactly.
If it was this room, that would be the name.
Do you get it?
What?
Wife wine.
Go to the lockers.
Exactly.
If it was this room, that would be the name.
Do you get it?
No, I'm confused.
Oh wait, continue.
Continue.
Just the names.
How do I pull up the map?
I'm asking the questions now.
Oh, okay.
When you're instructing me on where to go, you have to use the right words.
Okay?
Yes.
Okay.
The map that you just saw, you can access and display it on your monitor.
How?
If there's anything else you don't understand, check the keyword list.
What?
That list records keywords and phrases that are extracted from our dialogue.
Not only that, the list already contains words in the operator's manual.
How do I access this?
Anyway, how about giving me my first instruction?
What should I do?
Twerk.
Yes.
What is she doing?
What did I say?
Go to the lockers.
Okay.
I think she understood walk.
Gosh, it is so frustrating.
It's so weird not having my D-pad and my analog stick do anything.
Go to left locker.
It's locked.
This is basically Hey You Pikachu, but with guns.
It's so strange.
Oh, now it works, right?
We can unlock it.
Open.
And there's also a little note.
Yeah, there's also a little note.
Is that a key card?
A chip.
Take this chip and I eat it.
I'm gonna tell her to eat it.
Eat the chip.
She didn't even...
Oh, wait.
Read the note.
Okay.
I'm analyzing guard's note.
Oh, I don't think she knows how to read.
December reading material purchases.
Electronic newspaper magazines.
All reading materials are to be returned to their designated spaces after use.
Okay.
She can't read.
She just said that it was too sloppy, but she just doesn't know how to read.
I don't think she can read.
Hand holding the game.
Oh my goodness.
Walk away from the lockers.
No!
Stop!
Oh gosh.
Yes.
I imagine it hears me better because my mic is not good, right?
What'd she say?
Oh.
What?
Oh gosh.
She's so demanding.
It's making me feel things.
Interview footage.
December 24th, 2029.
Observatory restaurant.
On.
Honestly, my day looks the same when I let the voices take control.
Yeah.
Okay.
Ooh.
Wow.
Okay.
I haven't found a single lead since the chaos started.
She might be dead.
I have to check rooms one by one.
Oh my god.
Helen the reporter and you're Naomi.
Let's work together and find them.
Okay.
Okay, how about some guidance?
Where should I start searching?
It says cannot talk.
Oh wait, here we go.
Go into the room behind you.
Who?
No, where is that?
What?
The what?
What's happening?
Shoot!
Shoot head!
Run away!
Oh my god.
Number one, shoot!
Or run.
Oh nice, nice, nice.
Shoot head!
No.
Oh my god.
Shoot stomach!
Number one, stomach, shoot!
What do you mean?
What do you mean you can't do anymore?
Number one, shoot!
No!
Number one!
No.
Aim number one please!
No!
Shoot number one!
I can't tell if she's getting it or not.
I used that heal!
Shoot mouth!
Shoot mouth.
Oh nice, nice, nice.
Oh my god.
How do I bring up the map that she talked about?
Continue.
Show map.
Show map?
Dance.
Map.
Oh L1, L2.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Ok, so we are at shutter 9.
Ok.
It's the security room.
Security room.
Go to security room.
Oh my god.
I feel like I should give her a treat after that.
Now you know how they felt watching you play.
We didn't get everything in here.
I feel like give paw, you know.
What is she doing?
Go to vending machine.
Maybe she'll want something.
We have...
Check shiny.
What?
VTuber shoot.
Show VTuber.
VTuber turn around.
This is real back seating simulator.
Check machine.
What?
If you tell her to bark like a dog, she will.
No, she won't.
Bark.
Like a dog.
Drink.
Drink coffee?
Grab shiny object.
Oh my god.
She's looking.
Wait.
No, the other machine, Bozo.
Oh my god.
Oh, dispenser.
Check dispenser on the right.
No.
Oh my god.
Use your eyes, Rio.
Have some self worth.
Just do anything on your own.
Use colors.
Check dispenser in red vending machine.
It worked.
A ticket.
Microphone check.
Okay, what else we got in this room?
Holding cells.
Oh yeah, she was in one, right?
Oh, save point.
I don't know if I want to save yet.
I used a heal.
I don't even know what my inventory is like.
Oh, here we go.
Keywords.
Walk, run, stop, go back, check.
Oh.
Who is Naomi?
What is JSL?
What is that?
The table.
Okay.
Check notes.
Paper?
Oh gosh.
Look at magazines.
Ah.
Wow, a magazine.
Okay.
Work note?
Check work notes.
Oh, white paper maybe.
Check white paper.
Yeah.
What is that?
Report.
Read report.
What is this grade school stuff?
Check blue paper.
Yeah.
Check newspaper.
Oh my god.
Read newspaper.
So true.
That's it.
What else?
Oh, get me out.
Oh, what did I just say?
Don't, shh, shh, shh, shh.
Don't do anything.
Party, security, patrol details, key issues, scheduling and placement assignments, etc.
Check cup.
Ah.
Oh.
There's another one that's not empty though.
Drink coffee.
Yep.
Yeah, but she doesn't care.
She doesn't want it.
Spell eye cup.
Have you asked if she's played critically acclaimed video game series Metal Gear Solid?
That's a great question Rio.
Oh my gosh.
There's nothing over by shutter 9, right?
Guest room 1, I guess we could go to.
How do we even get through the shutters?
That's so scary.
$5 to ask her to bark like...
Okay, okay, okay.
Let me ask.
Bark like a dog.
Middle dog?
Arf, arf.
Or big dog?
Oof, oof.
Arf, arf.
Or big dog?
Oof, oof.
Arf, arf.
No way.
She does such a good one too.
Bark like a little dog.
Little dog?
Arf, arf.
Or big dog?
Oof, oof, oof.
Always wanted to play a game where I order a character around.
I order around a character that's either really hard of hearing or very special.
I definitely think she's hard of hearing.
Let's see.
Guest room.
Go to guest room 1.
For $5 we got Minto barking like a dog too.
Arf, arf.
Oof, oof.
She didn't put enough into it though I feel.
Oh no!
Baby Goron thanks for the five.
Get this.
Oh gosh.
Shoot mouse.
What the?
Run away!
Shoot mouse!
Okay, that works too.
Nice.
Oh gosh.
Okay, cool.
Go to guest room 2.
I think it was 2, right?
No urgency at all.
Don't you need to find Helen?
Wait, where are you going?
Oh, I said guest room 2.
I meant guest room 1.
Hold on.
Go to guest room 1.
Oh no.
Damn it.
The shutter is crazy.
What?
I was going to do a hot pose.
Okay.
We got to find the shutter key.
Got it.
Do a hot pose.
Sexy!
Go to guest room 1.
Okay.
She has no free will, this lady.
Sorry, my throat is a little...
A little ectoplasmy today.
That's kind of freaky.
I can just go into anybody's room that I wish?
Wow.
Ask her why her arms are like that.
Oh, the word is sexy.
Okay, okay.
Communication is stopped.
These loading screens.
Hello.
Excuse me.
Please, I hope there's nobody here.
So where should I begin checking?
Do a sexy pose.
Okay.
I'll leave.
Guys,
tell me to say something to her.
She leaves the room.
Where should I go?
Run to guest room 1.
Guest room 1.
Understood.
I'll go back.
Undo the door lock, please.
My god.
Every time it's something...
One of your requests.
She wants to leave.
Don't fart.
You guys are being too freaky.
This is why you'll never have a girl.
Okay.
Let's see.
A living area.
Save point.
Table.
I feel like I should be saving.
I'm worried about using all my stuff though.
Save point.
Why are you surprised that she leaves when you're doing Sekohara?
No!
She likes me.
Probably.
Yes.
Save.
Guest room 1.
Alright.
Let's go.
Oh, she's just been sitting on the floor?
Get up, silly.
Sit in chair.
What?
I guess that works too.
Oh no, I was gonna say there's probably something in here.
No!
What is that?
Shoot mouth.
Shoot head.
Shoot stomach.
Shoot mouth.
That's no good, no head.
Shoot head.
Oh, okay.
Shoot mouth.
I am God!
We're okay, girl.
I wonder if she'll do push-ups for me.
She's got a nice butt.
What?
It's Rio.
Only I can call her baby.
That's a friggin' mess.
Did he just spit on it?
My gosh.
Shoot man.
What?
Shoot...
Ew.
Rio is so sassy.
Get him!
Get his ass!
Oh my God!
That's such an arrogant jerk.
Yes, that was manager Tanaka.
He's in charge of this hotel.
Shoot manager Tanaka.
He told me to go rescue the guests.
Maybe he's the one who needs help.
Well, anyway.
What should we do now?
Shoot manager Tanaka.
Kill man.
The bathroom.
Okay.
He said he had... He said that the aliens had...
Yeah, he said that he had us trapped in the bathroom.
But like...
But it's just him.
Take a shower.
Rio.
Rio, please.
Please take a shower.
Take a shower.
Take a shower?
Not in your lifetime.
Rio.
Rio, please.
Please.
Remove shoes.
I think she's a little...
She's a little confused about that one.
Look under sink.
We got it.
Let's go.
Nice.
Box time.
Look in mirror.
Is my face dirty?
No.
I'll wash it later.
You can wash it now.
Wash face.
It's an ordinary wash stand.
There's nothing unusual.
Look at shower.
The shower itself is ordinary.
How do you know?
Over 90% of the water used here is recycled.
How would they go about cleaning that water?
Oh my gosh.
It's like a real gamble.
The water might be used by a stinky guy or it might be used water from a beautiful woman.
You don't know.
That's the gamble.
Test your luck.
How's your luck today?
You're awfully slow with instructions.
You're awfully slow with thinking.
Stop.
Yes.
What is this room?
Check bed.
What's that?
An ordinary bed but with soft springs in it for low gravity use.
I wonder what this is.
Is that a jelly?
A heal capsule.
She heals with jelly?
There doesn't seem to be anything else.
She uses the jelly.
No way.
I like how she just walks in circles.
Check luggage.
Yes.
Okay ma'am, you're making me dizzy.
Dresser.
Check dresser.
Suitcase.
I like my suitcase.
What does that mean?
Check trunk.
Two sassy ladies versus the alien invasion.
We got another chip.
What are these for again?
It was like a mic check or something, right?
What if I say that?
Mic check.
Check mirror.
Okay.
Remove clothes.
You heard me Rio.
Now you're going to play dumb.
You heard me.
Take off your clothes.
Stop.
No.
Yes.
There was some stuff in the living room.
Or living area.
Go to living area.
There it is.
What is that?
Check trunk?
Case?
What is that?
Luxury grade.
Check case.
Okay.
Oh god.
Check camera.
What?
No.
Stop.
Living area.
Sekuhara simulator Rio.
No!
I'm doing my best with her!
Gray case.
Case.
Briefcase.
Open it.
Open briefcase.
Inspect.
What is JSL?
Oh we got another mic check.
Zoom in?
What?
Zoom in.
Oh god.
Zoom out.
Zoom in on ass.
Damn it.
Oh it's blind.
What is that?
Is it a phone?
Check phone?
I see.
Does it have any...
Read document.
Wow.
Zoom in?
Damn.
It just knows...
The other one was mic check.
Mic check.
What?
Check wine.
Check phone?
Ok.
It doesn't have any messages or anything?
There is literally a red light?
Ok.
Go to table.
Oh we are going to drink the wine?
Ok.
Hold on.
Wait.
Check cup.
Drink coffee.
Yeah.
Why not?
You get the caffeine.
Get your blood pumped.
Check paper.
Rio.
Oh gosh.
Is it going to be able to...
Pamphlet.
No!
Stop!
Drink wine.
Living area.
Chug wine.
Drink wine.
White girl wasted.
No!
Stop!
I don't know what she is picking up man.
Check table.
Yes.
Read pamphlet.
No!
Please!
Stop!
No!
What do you mean yes?
Yes.
Check table.
She is trying to get me to the bed.
Say read.
Read.
She doesn't know how.
She can't read.
I'm going to read it myself.
This station is home to the hotel of ultimate luxury, solely for the chosen.
JSL travel agency.
Grab camera.
Check camera.
Take it.
Why don't you want it?
It could be good evidence.
1980 model film camera.
No film, no batteries.
Ok, never mind.
It's useless.
Unit lost.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Actual ante.
Ok, I think save.
No.
Save point.
How can it be manual focus if it has no lens?
It's like actual manual.
Like the most manual.
Ok, save.
Yes.
Let's leave.
She is going to be sitting on the floor again.
Are you ok?
Stop.
She is so obsessed with me.
Stop trying to get me to the bed, you creep Rio.
You are giving me mixed signals.
Look outside.
Ok.
You know what?
I should have probably expected that to be honest.
Emergency panel.
Wait, wait, wait.
I didn't notice.
I thought we checked everything in here.
She is gaslighting me.
It's Gorbin.
There is someone else alive out there.
Bedroom 1.
Understood.
I'll go back.
Undo the door lock please.
Ok.
I have to do this every time.
Alright.
Hold on.
There was the emergency panel.
Then we can leave.
Oh my gosh.
Help please.
Help.
Alright.
It was...
Emergency panel.
Yeah.
What is that?
What's the emergency panel?
I didn't even see her walking around.
Ok.
Oh, but it wasn't because it was...
Oh.
What?
That's it?
Oh my god.
Ok.
Nevermind.
We were supposed to check that and then go into the bedroom.
And then find it in the bathroom.
Leave.
Oh.
Go outside.
Why would I say leave?
You don't know what I'm talking about.
Gosh.
Ok.
So shutter 7.
Shutter 7.
Nice.
There we go.
Overall though, the voice recognition, it could be, you know, obviously way worse.
It's actually, you know, I'm progressing through the game.
I'm able to... I'm able to fight.
I'm able to do it.
You just did it.
Auto control emergency shutter can now be opened closed.
Open.
I hope that we won't get sucked into space.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Middle eye.
Shoot.
Right eye.
Left eye.
Shoot.
Oh.
Nope.
Left eye.
Shoot.
Oh.
Red eye.
Shoot.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, Ryu.
You and me are the dream team.
Oh yeah.
The dream team, the dream team, the dream team.
Boom!
Ya'll fine!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
I want you to think for yourself for once, Riel.
Oh.
Oh my god, this just came up all...
Wait, actually no.
I think I tapped it on accident.
What is special word?
Oh, these are the ones!
Microphone check.
Do you think Riel knows I'm talking?
Wow!
She says I'm easy to follow!
Sorry, my responses are limited.
You must ask the right question.
Ask her, what's your sign?
Why are you so sassy?
Turn around.
No!
Stop!
Ok, Riel.
We're going to guest room 2, baby.
Guest room 2.
Oh, we should have zoomed.
You're so right.
She did turn around, true.
There is someone who needs help in this room.
Where?
Ok, Riel.
Let's go girl!
Oh my god!
Do something for yourself!
Oh god, she's useless without me.
No, Riel!
She's useless without me!
Shoot, Riel!
She's not listening to me.
Oh my gosh.
Get reinforcements!
Uh-oh.
What if I start telling the monster what to do instead?
Ok.
Open!
I opened it!
What do you want?
Oh, I needed to close it.
First death.
She's like, help me!
Help me!
Dang!
We're going to have to watch the cutscene all over again.
Sorry guys.
Ok.
Help!
Get up!
Stop!
She wants me so bad you guys.
She wants me so bad!
Leave!
Oh my god!
Stop!
Go outside.
What is she doing?
I'm Zoolander.
I can't turn left!
She wants me so bad!
She's going to start being like, Rio, who's that?
My name is Naomi.
Can I skip these?
Ok, no.
Sorry guys.
We're going to have to watch these again.
Continue.
My dad!
Ok.
What is it?
Shutter 7.
Bogos minted!
No bed.
No.
Oh my god!
She is so... Ok, open.
Alright.
Alright, alright, alright.
Oh!
I have to fight this thing again.
I forgot.
Middle I shoot!
Right I shoot!
Left I shoot!
Red I shoot!
What the hell?
Past Rio didn't get shot at?
She didn't take damage?
What?
Present Rio sucks!
Gaming.
Meow.
She doesn't meow.
She only barks.
Bark.
What is that?
Oh she thought...
Bark like a dog.
I like when she looks at the camera.
Why is she shrugging that?
Meow like a cat.
Huh?
Guest bedroom 3.
Alright, we are going to have to watch her run all the way here.
And then run away.
The music is kind of awesome though.
The static camera as she runs kills me.
It's so funny.
Weird curving hallway.
We are on a space station so it actually makes sense.
This is going to be the boss later, isn't it?
Are
those nipples?
Shut her!
Close!
She's going to close on it.
Wait am I...
I thought it would die.
I thought it would get shut in between.
Dang.
Joy!
Thank you for the pink!
Maybe I should have had it shut on it.
You're welcome.
What are we hawing about?
Someone is walking.
Get your gun out.
Revolver Ocelot!
Building cell.
I had an operator open it for me.
That idiot.
Inside the cell no alien would have reached you.
I thought you died.
It will take a lot more than those aliens to kill me.
Aliens?
So those are aliens?
Hey, the good news is that a shuttle with a rescue team is on the way.
I ran into a researcher in the testing ward and he said they caught a radio signal.
I've got to tell the others about this right away.
They could be demons.
This could be doom.
Hey, operator.
Look after her, okay?
Oh yeah, here.
Take this.
It's the voice password for one of the suites.
The researcher I met.
He's hiding in the sun suite.
I'm going to keep looking for survivors.
Make your way to the receiving port.
Got it?
This suite faces the sun the entire time.
No, please, revolver!
Ocelot, please!
Think of the tan though.
No tan.
Okay.
Spider monkey.
I thought she was going to say spider monkey.
Yes, ma'am.
Search every room.
Okay, we're on...
What about the lady?
That was beyond shutter 4.
I think we just lost her.
Guest room 2.
Yeah, she's cooked cooked.
When a girl she's protecting dies.
I'm out.
No!
Open!
I think Naomi is...
She caused all of this.
That was handgun... caracal?
What?
Uh...
This room doesn't look so hot.
The save point.
I'm glad there's a save point in every room.
That's kind of nice.
Save point.
There's like blue gunk everywhere.
And blood!
Uh-oh.
And a dress.
Hot dog.
Maybe she'll want to shower in this bathroom.
Maybe.
Yeah, I feel like I need to save a lot in this game.
I'm not going to lie.
Okay, cool.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
New fit.
Could we?
Stand.
Oh wait, I pressed the wrong button.
Arise.
Stand.
Stop.
Okay.
Emergency panel.
Arise.
She doesn't understand.
Yeah, man.
Let's grab that.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Stop.
Let me give you command.
Living area.
Rockbiter, thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Check dress.
Vom Vom.
Wear dress.
No!
But you would be running around so much more freely.
Less restriction.
What is a Vom Vom Vom?
Yeah, she just called us poor.
Check gloves.
Wait, there is something underneath the table.
We got another ticket.
Low kick?
I think that's everything.
Low kick.
No, no.
Check under table.
Maybe she can look under.
What?
Okay, nevermind.
Vom Vom for room.
Oh my god, you scared me.
Shoot mouth.
Oh my god!
Dodge!
Shoot mouth.
Shoot stomach.
Oh my god, this thing is... Shoot mouth.
Shoot mouth.
Shoot stomach.
Nice.
Okay, so the blue ones are stomach.
Other ones are mouth.
No good?
Or no, it's good.
There was a very... I was about to say a pregnant pause.
Goddammit.
I can't say that word anymore around you guys because you get insane.
There was a very...
Oh my gosh.
Let's see.
Check bed.
Maybe CPR the woman.
Oh, she got a second of the Vom Vom for room's dress.
Check dress.
Dress.
No, no.
Stop.
Bed.
Dress.
Room.
Yeah, she did.
Side table?
No, the side table.
Nine months of...
Thanks for nine months.
Oh wow, corpse.
CPR.
She didn't even entertain it.
Check book.
What is it?
It's a catalogue.
It's a Vom Vom for room's spring collection.
Member catalogue, not for sale.
Read book.
There's a shiny.
Shiny.
What?
What the hell?
I didn't know you were into that.
Read catalogue.
Listen to this kid.
What is it?
What is that?
Code note.
Oh.
I...
We...
Wait, one, five.
Yeah.
I'm not... I know Roman numerals.
I'm not stupid.
Okay, never mind.
I know it.
When the game out freaks me into bed.
Girl, bed, now.
I sound like I'm from a damn romance novel.
Like, girl, bed, now.
Check me out in love and deep space.
Lamp.
Yeah, I'm talking about the lamp.
Go to lamp.
Okay, yeah.
To the lamp.
Make her boneless.
Make me just like the aliens.
Bed.
Oh.
She's getting her steps in.
Maybe, what is that?
Oh, night stand.
No.
Night stand.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes.
Go to night stand.
Yes, there is.
You liar.
There's literally a dress.
Check night stand.
Oh.
Box.
No.
Phone.
Yes.
Let's check the dresser too, but hold on.
Bed.
Yes.
Phone.
No, please.
Bed.
Go to bed, my little kitten.
What do I call that thing?
What is this thing?
The thing that's lighting up.
What is that?
If I say box, she starts to walk.
White box.
No ma'am.
White.
Check dresser.
Oh wait, I forgot that's the actual dresser.
Okay.
There's a heal capsule.
Yippee.
Energy.
Oh my gosh, this is literal jelly.
Check mirror.
Okay.
Red bag.
It's a Von Von Varom.
I knew it.
Steal.
She's dead, what is she going to do?
Shoot the mirror?
You can do that.
Shoot mirror.
Wow.
Loot.
No, no, no.
Steal jewelry.
What?
Move bag?
Take bag.
You said it was cute.
Bed.
No, no, no.
Go to the bed.
Oh god.
Stop.
Why is it when I talk with a sexy voice she doesn't listen to me?
Bed.
I think maybe the game hates sexy men voice.
It's a Von Von Varom.
We still... I don't know what that thing is you guys.
I don't know what that thing is.
I have no idea.
I have no idea what that is.
Jewelry box.
Oh my god.
What is it?
Safe?
Check safe.
Oh my god.
We can...
I got you Rio.
I got you.
It's a Von Von Varom number maybe.
Okay.
What's a Von Von code?
Oh shoot.
What's the dress?
I don't know.
We are at 2021?
Really?
Thank you.
I wonder what it is.
We got the shutter key.
Maybe they knew what was going to happen.
Bathroom.
Nice.
I think she likes me guys.
She listens to me a lot.
What the... Shower.
What do you mean by that?
Take a shower.
Mirror.
Someone said... Wait.
Punch mirror.
Is there going to be something behind one of these?
I wonder.
Bottle.
Yeah.
Makeup.
Check makeup.
Take makeup.
Rio, don't you want to live in luxury?
Don't you want to live in luxury?
Okay.
Let's go.
I guess that's it from here.
Save point.
Use makeup though.
So true.
That's disgusting.
Bullet count?
Can I run out of bullets in this game?
Does shooting the mirror use bullets?
Voice recognition average.
Voice recognition best.
Wow.
Number of commands.
Rio is like Dante.
She manifests the bullets.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go.
Yeah, let me ask about the bullets, right?
Oh wait.
There was another thing.
Low kick.
Stop.
God Rio, I know you want me so bad, but please girl, contain yourself.
There are people watching.
Let's see.
What else do we have?
Oh wait.
Do you have any friends?
Stop.
She's avoiding the question.
Do you have any friends?
I wonder if Naomi is alive.
Do you think Naomi is alive?
Stop.
What is the point?
What is the point of our special questions if we can't even... Every single one.
Every single one.
What's the relationship with Gino?
Gino.
Who is Gino?
Click them?
Can I?
Instead?
Oh wait.
I think I have to right click them.
Or not right.
Square click them.
Nope.
Nothing works.
Oh whoops.
What should we do?
Oh you gotta say consultation first.
Oh.
Consultation.
She's so cute.
Do you have any friends?
Zoom.
She's just like me for real for real.
Consultation.
I wanted to zoom in her face.
I love the dead lady in the background.
I wonder if Naomi is alive.
You think so?
What are you looking for?
Sorry but I'd like to keep that a secret for now.
Do you trust me?
Damn.
What's the relationship with Gino?
Gino and I?
We're just co-workers.
For some reason he's very nice to me.
He tends to be presumptuous and bullish.
For some reason he's really nice to you.
Let me see.
Who is Helen Johnson?
Okay.
Excited to say that I took my kitty Georgie to the vet today.
Got him all vaxxed up and chipped.
So he's now officially my fur baby!
Oh my gosh little Georgie!
Thank you battle beetle!
Ask her about Metal Gear.
What was it?
Oh Helen Joh- Who is Helen Johnson?
I see.
I see, I see.
Is a rescue team coming?
Consultation?
Do you like my sunglasses?
Okay that should be everything in here so...
Leave.
Oh my god I forgot that she does not know the command.
Leave the room.
Wait what?
What did she do?
Why is that still shiny?
Oh because of the code.
Nevermind.
Go outside.
Yes.
Ask her about the Patriots.
Why are you asking me about the lalilulelo?
Can you imagine if she said that?
Zyra!
Thank you for three months!
Can't hear you over the clapping of...
Okay.
This is a code na-
Bugles printed?
Bugles printed!
Someone help get my photos printed!
Naomi!
How do you know?
Okay.
She's calling from somewhere.
My girl.
She's alive!
Guest room 3.
Go to guest room 3.
How do we know that's my girl though?
How do we know?
You think Rio can do a flip?
Probably.
She's so cool.
She's a little slow at walking, but you know.
Oh this game was published and developed by Sony.
Oh!
And then Konami published it.
I see.
Alright,
who are we fighting in here?
Who's dead or alive?
Get your guns out.
Get your guns out!
Ambush!
Turn around!
What?
Shoot mouth 3!
No.
Run away!
Shoot mouth!
I don't think she's shooting anything.
Run away!
Shoot mouth!
Why can't she hit?
Run away!
Maybe that works.
She's doing her own dance moves.
Shoot mouth!
Oh that works too, yeah.
No!
Shoot mouth!
Turn right!
Shoot mouth.
Shoot stomach?
Oh my god.
What?
Golly.
Stop.
I didn't say anything.
Rio!
Girl, girl, get your hormones in check please.
Are the Patriots Rio?
She wants me so bad.
Oh my gosh.
Emergency panel.
She's turning into Sonic the Hedgehog.
Oh!
It's there.
Oh no.
What is that?
Yellow thing.
Shutter key.
Oh.
Move shutter key.
Ok, but there is a thing underneath.
Yellow.
Camera check?
Zoom in.
Oh damn it.
I wish when I zoomed I could move around.
Camera check.
What?
Hold on.
What did we just get?
I just did that.
Low kick.
We have to do the low kick.
I guess it's not blinking anymore.
I guess we did it.
Table?
A feast.
Oh my gosh.
Let's go.
Oh no.
Eat food.
Yeah.
What?
Why not?
9 months already.
Vladido.
Thank you for the 9 months.
That zoom was a bit off target, Mint.
You'll get it next time.
Drink wine.
No way.
Is she going to do it?
Please Rio.
Please drink wine.
I said please.
Don't BS me Rio.
Check meal.
Oh my God.
Shoot stomach.
Shoot head.
Oh my God.
Shoot mouth.
Shoot head.
Shoot stomach.
Oh my God.
Shoot head.
Shoot mouth.
Oh my God.
Good job girl.
She runs away.
I love when she misinterprets me.
Shoot stomach.
Do the low kick.
Low kick.
Shoot mouth.
Shoot head.
I think it's working.
Low kick.
Shoot mouth.
Reload.
Not at the table please.
Run away.
Shoot mouth.
Oh!
We got him when he jumped.
Nice.
She's really shooting that table good.
I don't know how to get her to stop shooting the table.
Check table.
It has so many bullet holes in it now.
Can you imagine?
Wine.
Blue wine.
Heal.
Check meal.
Yeah.
A heal capsule.
Nice.
Flip table.
For real.
I think they can eat this still.
It doesn't look touched at all.
Blue bottle.
Yes.
Champagne.
How did that work?
Drink Champagne.
Why does she understand that?
Why does that work?
Living area.
I don't understand.
I don't understand why that works.
Coffee.
There is a coffee.
Ok.
Nevermind.
Save point.
Ok.
This feels like if you had a level 90 Pokemon and one gym badge.
I'm going to save.
You don't have to tell me.
You don't have to remind me.
It's ok.
Ok.
Yes.
Joy!
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
I gotta get more.
I don't know why my throat is all icky.
The save point.
Ok.
Yeah.
The save point.
Ok.
What should I tell her to do?
Lie down.
Lay down.
That's what I say when I'm really excited for something.
I'll be sitting.
Roll over.
Jump.
High five.
Do a sexy pose.
Sexy pose.
Sexy.
Sex?
Stop!
Shoot mouth.
Shoot stomach.
Low kick.
Did that work?
Shoot stomach.
Run away.
Shoot stomach too.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Kick off!
What?
Turn...run away.
Ok.
That works actually.
Run away.
Oh my god.
Shoot mouth.
Shoot stomach.
Shoot number two.
Shoot mouth.
Shoot stomach.
Oh my god.
Kick it off.
Low kick.
Run away.
Shoot number two.
Number two.
Turn around.
Oh my god.
Kick!
Get it off!
Low kick.
Shoot...run away!
Run away.
Shoot mouth.
Shoot stomach.
Shoot head.
Shoot mouth.
Shoot stomach.
Shoot head.
Ok.
Shoot stomach.
Oh my god.
No.
Shoot stomach.
Holy moly.
We wasted the health.
Oh there is one there too.
Remember you can say dodge.
Nasty.
Ok.
Good golly.
Goodness gracious.
I wonder if the rumors are true.
That the game can understand your commands better if you use the Ara Ara voice.
Stormtrooper aim.
I swear.
I swear to god.
Check bed.
That's where our initial...
Oh there is something on the side table.
No?
That's not anything?
Check dresser.
Under dresser.
I don't think so.
This is what it feels like to control my TV with my Alexa.
Check mirror.
Ok.
Brown box.
I don't think... I don't think... Cigar case.
Open cigar case.
Hashtag Berserker.
Thank you for the 9 months.
What are these chips?
What are they?
Anything else in there?
Check corpse.
Absolute cinema.
Joy!
Thank you for the $50!
Thank you for another $50!
Oh my goodness.
Thank you!
Ok.
Bathroom.
Sword Master, Custodian of Shakespeare, Royal Guard.
Pay respects.
Starting to get hungry guys.
Wait there really is nothing in here.
Wow.
Is there nothing in here?
Was there anything outside?
I'm not sure.
What's the plan for dinner?
I didn't think I was going to get hungry.
I think I have some more chicken.
Eat.
Check bed.
I want to...
Oh.
Ok.
Go outside.
Damn.
Ok, nevermind.
I guess we are done here.
We are going to get another Bogo's Binted call.
From maybe Naomi?
Maybe a skinwalker?
That's a great question.
Shutter 3.
Hold on, no.
I want to get to snack.
Is that ok?
Real quick?
You can just listen to her ramble a little bit.
I'm going to go grab a snack.
I'm starting to feel like I'm going to get shaky all of a sudden.
If I don't eat something.
I usually...
Hey, what the heck?
I'm not immune system.
My metabolism.
It's going nutso today.
Ok, I'll be right back.
Uh...
I need guidance?
Hello?
I guess I've been left to my own devices.
What are you doing?
Bzz.
Time's up.
Oh, where is she going?
Ma'am?
Hello?
Rio?
What are you doing?
Where is she going?
Hello?
What is happening?
Where is she going?
Rio?
Stop?
Yes.
She said time's up.
Time's up and took off.
Hold on.
I'm going to have a brief food intermission.
I'm so sorry you guys.
I started getting so...
I have some fries and chicken that I made earlier.
Hold on.
I'll even put on some BGM.
So you don't even just hear me chewing everything.
One second.
This one.
Sorry.
Brief food intermission.
Do you have any sauce?
I didn't get any because I was in a rush.
I wanted to have the chicken with some ranch.
You know?
But it's okay.
Just to have a little.
It's still yummy without it.
I just really started to feel so hungry.
You want a bite?
Made some gnocchi with chicken and a creamy pesto sauce.
Okay, bragging.
Sounds way better than my...
My sauce-less chicken.
Am I having fun?
I am!
I'm having so much fun.
Such a silly game.
I'm wondering how long this will take to beat.
I truly can't figure it out at all.
I wish I could play and eat at the same time.
I think this is trapped on the PS2.
JLPT results were finally posted yesterday.
I passed N3!
Congratulations!
Thanks for wishing me good luck back in the end of November.
Congratulations, Paul!
Beat the game while chewing.
Eating challenge?
Yeah, right?
Oh, sorry.
There we go.
I never played Hey You Pikachu.
Some people have brought that up before, but...
What was that for?
Oh, N64.
Never had that.
Did not have... I had a Gameboy growing up, but...
Did not have an N64.
It was basically like...
You only get one console.
What do you want?
And I said...
PlayStation!
Noki Mindo eating is cute.
Thank you toy!
For the ping.
But then why would I get a PlayStation and not...
Get Metal Gear Solid?
What was wrong with me?
Have you heard of the official life-sized Gardevoir?
I saw it, yeah.
I did.
I think though because I never had a Nintendo 64, like I never got...
That's why I'm such a bad player at like Mario Kart and stuff.
I never got to play it.
The first time I played Mario Kart was just like a couple years ago.
I think...
I guess now...
Almost five years ago.
Because it was...
Because it was when I first started YouTubing.
God's favorite potato, welcome to membership!
Like I never played Smash.
Okay, I think I'm good enough to continue without...
Without finishing.
We are G2G.
Good to go.
Alright, we're going to...
Why did she go all the way down here?
Shutter 3.
G2G baby.
Run.
Yeah.
Six years old, I wanted hot wheels.
My older brother convinced me to ask for an N64 at Christmas instead.
Smart brother.
Alright, be prepared.
I'm doing it.
Ugly.
Shoot, middle eye.
Back up.
Shoot, left eye.
Nice.
Shoot, red eye.
What's wrong with you?
Nice flip.
That was the most...
That was so dramatic, Ryo, for what?
That's right, it has a voice thing, right?
Honeymoon mode?
Oh yeah.
Ride.
Say it, say it Ryo.
What?
What do I say?
She didn't give it to me!
Wait!
You didn't give it to me!
How was I supposed to know that wouldn't work?
Guest room 4.
Oh that works, whatever.
Oh my god!
How was I supposed to know?
What's down that hallway?
Shutter 2.
Infirmary.
Equipment room.
Guest room 4.
Okay.
Unlock.
You're welcome.
I can't believe that we would get rejected like this.
On our honeymoon.
This room is empty.
It's not empty!
Dodge!
Shoot tongue!
Shoot front limb!
That works too.
Shoot inner mouth!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're gonna die.
Leave!
No, no, no.
Leave room.
No, no, no, no, no.
Go outside!
Low kick!
Oh my god.
Leave!
I didn't save until like a while, a while ago.
Suddenly hand monsters.
And there is three things in there!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Alright.
Go outside.
Maybe this time though we can...
We can actually not take any damage from this stupid guy over here.
I didn't want to heal because people said try not to heal so much.
What's it called?
Shutter 3.
Rio 3 will be the best one for sure.
This is the best timeline.
This
will open that shutter.
Hurry up and analyze.
Got it.
Shoot right eye!
Run away!
Shoot left eye!
Oh dang it.
Nice.
Shoot middle eye!
Shoot left eye!
Nice.
Shoot red eye!
We're good.
Guys I won't fumble it this time.
Guys I won't fumble this time.
Honeymoon mode?
What would do something to riz her?
What would be something?
Ride?
In this case I guess it's me.
It's my turn.
That must be me.
Ok.
Hold on.
I gotta take a sippy.
Another voice.
In order to undo the lock to the sun suite I guess we need another piece of the voice password.
Where should I start looking?
It didn't even give me a chance!
Ok, let's go back to room 3 and we'll save now.
Go to guest room 3.
I went down the wrong pipe.
Wrong pipe.
You didn't take the chance.
Red.
We'll save in here.
We'll save in here and then go to the next room and hopefully not die.
Save panel.
No!
Oh, save point.
Did we open the door in this room?
Yeah, because this is the dinner room.
And there's a guy dead in there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ok, nice.
Let's go!
Check the living area and the cigar box again.
Someone said something about the code being there.
And the cigar box?
Stand up.
Bedroom?
In the cigar box?
Oh, god!
What?
Shoot mouth!
Shoot mouth.
Low kick.
Oh, shoot head.
Oh my god.
Shoot head.
Shoot mouth.
Low kick.
Die, Rio.
Die.
It's your turn to die.
Why did you use the heal, Rio?
Rio!
Persona!
It's not attacking me at all.
I want to...I want to reload.
Oh,
here we go.
Rio, this is what you get for healing instead of shooting like I told you.
07 Rio 3.
In the bedroom!
Alright.
That one I don't think counts because...
I don't think that counts.
IMHO.
Don't count that as a death.
Why did the monsters respawn?
There better be something actually in that.
There better actually be something in the cigar box, you guys.
If I'm getting one guide, I swear to...I swear.
I think the prior save was before we opened this door.
Yeah, exactly.
Stand up.
You never went in there after reloading.
I didn't?
Really?
Bedroom.
Oh!
Oh wait, really?
Oh my goodness.
Well then we needed to go in here anyway.
Run away!
Oh, run away!
Shoot mouse!
Shoot...run away!
Run!
Run away!
Stand up!
Oh my god, shoot head!
Shoot mouth!
Shoot stomach!
Oh, I can't!
I can't deal with this!
Oh my god.
The other one is trying to get a suck, but it can't get in.
Ok, I'm not trying to do like a perfect run or anything, but sheesh!
Just listen to what I have to say, please!
It's real!
Ok.
Real 5.
Stand up.
Bedroom.
Ok.
I can't figure out which is best for like these other colors either.
Low kick!
Shoot mouth!
Run away!
Shoot head!
Shoot stomach!
Run away!
Shoot 2!
There we go.
Ok.
Shoot mouth!
Shoot stomach!
Shoot head!
Shoot mouth!
Shoot stomach!
Shoot head!
Shoot mouth!
Shoot stomach!
Run away!
No!
Shoot mouth?
Where are you?
Shoot stomach!
Shoot stomach?
Run away!
Kick?
Shoot mouth!
I mean...
Shoot stomach!
Reload!
Oh shoot!
Shoot stomach!
No!
Turn around!
Run!
Shoot stomach!
Oh my god!
Run!
Oh my god, please!
Shoot stomach!
Shoot head!
Shoot stomach twice!
Shoot, shoot, shoot!
Shoot stomach!
Shoot!
Run away!
Shoot stomach!
Reload!
Run away!
Low kick!
Ah, run!
Shoot stomach!
Oh my...
Now we can move on!
Thank god that bullets are not... Can you imagine?
Oh my god, can you imagine?
Dresser...
Can you imagine if...
Oh my god!
Ok...
Under dresser
Cigar box
Open cigar case I'll save you guys, I will after this.
You don't have to spam save There is nothing in the cigar case Check cigar case
Check mirror
Shoot mirror Oh!
That's not...
Just to make sure, you know.
They are going to notice now that there is a bullet in him.
Shoot mirror.
So I definitely got one guide, I guess.
Check corpse.
So I think I definitely...
Well, I mean I had to come back in here anyway, but I definitely got one guide.
Very nice, thank you.
Save panel.
Save point.
No!
Stop.
What's it called?
Save point.
Okay.
You guys one guide me.
How could you?
Stand up.
Okay.
I don't think there was anything else.
Actually, check bed.
I don't remember if there was anything here before.
For anyone who came in, we had died.
And I forgot to recheck this room.
But somebody said that there was a...
That there was a code to the other door in here, but they were wrong.
Senar, thank you for the 10 gifts.
Thank you.
Okay, so...
Go outside.
Hope not spam, try saying the target then shoot.
But I don't know, I really...
So do I say shoot number one or do I say number one shoot?
Like I don't know though, I don't remember...
I don't think I'm...
Hold on, let me see.
Like it's the...
It's the order of operations that is confusing me.
Cause it's like, do I say...
Shoot one...
Number one head?
Or do I say...
Shoot number...
Do I say...
Number two shoot head or head shoot?
I don't know.
You can just say a body part.
Yeah, but someone is saying...
Tell me to shoot...
Or someone is saying to...
Oh my gosh, real.
Someone is saying to...
Do...
The target, say what target it is.
Oh my gosh, these are the items I have.
Oh my gosh, wait.
The chips, the chips.
What are the chips?
Portable...
Wait, no.
A trendy and popular collectible item.
Something happens every time four chips are collected.
Well, I have four.
So...
What happened?
Nothing.
Okay, anyway.
Guess...
No, hold on.
It's the order.
Say shoot after the target.
Okay.
Guest room four.
Run to guest room four.
No, no, no, no.
Stop.
Run to guest room four.
Okay.
Okay, this one is hard.
This room is scary.
Alright.
Open.
Thanks.
Let's go baby.
Wait, you can...
Oh gosh, everybody is telling me different things.
It's confusing me.
I'm confused.
Dodge.
In her mouth.
Tongue.
Front limb.
Body.
Tongue.
Number two.
Head.
Stomach.
Mouth.
No, why do you always do it with...
Number one.
Front limb.
Dodge left.
Okay.
Mouth.
Oh my god.
In her mouth.
Dodge.
Number three.
In her mouth.
Heal.
Please heal.
Recover.
Oh my god.
Number two.
Stomach.
Tongue.
Mouth.
In her mouth.
Get off.
Number two.
Stomach.
Dodge.
Number two.
Run away.
In her mouth.
Heal.
Recover.
In her mouth.
Tongue.
Run.
Front limb.
Run away.
Run.
Tongue.
Run away.
Body.
No.
Run.
Dodge left.
Oh my god.
Finally.
In her mouth.
Dodge left.
Number one.
In her mouth.
Number two.
Stomach.
Mouth.
In her mouth.
Oh my god.
Oh my... Is that a sword on the table?
Zoom.
Nevermind.
Living area.
Grab the katana.
Oh.
Oh wow!
Is that the groom?
Bottle?
Nevermind.
Living area.
Are those bullets?
What is that?
What is this?
I don't... Check body.
Well fought, Minda.
The voices.
What do you mean?
Behind the couch.
Yes.
Oh.
This person is dead.
He was hiding here.
In hopes of finding protection.
Voice password.
We got the second voice.
Now we can get into the sun suite.
Yes.
Okay.
Let's go.
No, no, no.
There is so much to do.
What the hell?
Check chair.
What are you talking about?
There is no save point in here.
Check chair.
Helmet?
Maybe wear it.
Wear helmet.
Girl, your priorities are real!
Sword?
Yeah, what is that?
Check steel pipe.
Weapon.
Take steel pipe.
Girl, what?
You can have other weapons.
No!
Bullets?
Stop.
Check living area.
Oh, I see a health pack too.
I see a health pack.
What are those?
Are they bullets?
What are they?
Green box.
Yes.
It is...
Everybody, place your bets.
What do you think this is?
It's...
Rations?
Check rations.
Move rations.
Metal gear.
Eat rations.
But there is a heal right above...
Check rations.
No, but...
Shiny!
Check bottle?
Oh...
Stop, stop.
Stop.
Living area.
Check under ration.
Oh my god, finally.
Don't act like you made that discovery Rio.
Don't act like you are the one who did that.
Don't act like it.
Emergency panel.
The save point is in the bedroom?
This is so messed up.
But the battle was so hard in this room.
We can't use this anymore.
This one is broken too?
Do you guys think I should go in there?
Without saving?
Bedroom.
Here we go.
Oh, nevermind.
It's normal.
Save point.
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Blanket.
White.
Please don't edit my face.
I can't imagine you guys.
I can already see you guys.
Editing my face.
On to the
thing that...
Projector.
That's what I said.
Don't do it.
Space station.
The Bloor map?
What did she say?
It's the Bloor map.
You're in the monitor room.
It's pretty far from the hotel section.
And...
How did she say that?
That's the receiving port.
If Gina's story is true, the rescue team will be arriving here.
We're close.
Paper.
Paper?
There are papers all over.
Which one do you mean?
Have you guys ever seen that bird that like...
They'll give him something and they'll be like, what's this?
And Apollo will be like, Apollo, what's this?
And he'll go, metal.
Or he'll go, paper.
Or he'll go, glass.
That's how I feel.
I'm just saying, paper.
Shrug.
Check green paper.
Yes.
No.
Questionnaire.
Read questionnaire.
Those are some big words.
Check blue.
We let her do what she wants to do.
Zoom.
No.
What?
Yes.
Bed.
There's another chip.
She's zooming.
Check table.
What is the blue thing?
What should I say?
This game feels like Minto roleplaying as chat backseating the other VTuber.
Oh, blueprint?
Blueprint.
Oh, I thought it was a blanket.
I thought it was a blanket.
Manager check completed.
Please let us know how you feel about our hotel, including suggestions and requests.
We will use your feedback so that we may serve you better in the future.
She's comfy brained.
So true.
Dresser.
The dresser.
Read note.
Read letter.
Letter.
Invitation.
Steal money.
After you steal the money maybe.
Dresser.
Do what with what?
Take money.
Read invitation.
Got the meowy hands.
Look under invitation.
I know.
No, but the thing on the back.
Oh, how do I say that?
Under invitation.
What?
Why are you so violent, Rio?
Chill out.
Turn over invitation.
Flip invitation.
I know.
I don't know how to get her.
Flip.
The invitation.
Check invitation.
I've tried behind.
I've tried it.
I'll try again.
Behind invitation.
Oh my god.
This is not hot dog moment.
Turn over invitation.
Check back of invitation.
Oh my god.
Yes.
What did we get?
Oh no, do I get to play a game with her?
Check mirror.
Rio, your confidence.
Wow.
Holy moly.
Okay, check bed.
By the bed.
Don't leave yet.
Save point.
Nice.
So confident, yet so dumb.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Yippee!
Let's go.
Is this Rio 5 or 6?
6, I think.
Alright.
I think we did get everything in here.
I did check the emergency panel.
It was broken.
I checked the table.
Okay.
Go outside.
Yep.
Good girl.
I want to see her do the sexy pose.
We still haven't seen that.
I'll ask her when she leaves here.
Oh wait, we might get up.
Oh, I can't talk.
Sexy pose.
Do a sexy pose.
Sexy pose for me, little lady.
Little lady.
Break?
Give me something to break!
Pose.
Yes, girl!
Pyrobug!
Thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Alright, we are going to the sun suite.
We get to save my part of the ladder guys.
Let's go.
Run to sun suite.
Honeymoon mode?
This would be so embarrassing.
Just give me a key.
Even the very shadow that you cast in sunlight.
Authentication successful.
The groom may now read the second portion.
Luckily I have no blood to spike.
Oh my god.
Second...
A document with the ocean.
Authentication unsuccessful.
Will the groom please read clearly?
I want to monopolize.
Authentication successful.
So far so good.
You may both enter.
How is that romantic?
What does that even mean?
I'm literally just saying I want to play Monop...
Even the very shadow that you cast in sunlight.
I want to monopolize.
Authentication unsuccessful.
What?
Will the groom please face the bride while reading?
In case you forgot, we also have to say both lines of the poem at the same time.
Oh ok.
One more time.
Oh shoot.
The bride may now read the first portion.
What?
Even the very shadow that you cast in sunlight.
Authentication successful.
The groom may now read the second portion.
Ok.
It's talking about you.
Me.
Ok.
I want to monopolize.
Authentication successful.
You may both enter.
We got it!
Ready?
What am I doing?
Even the very shadow that you cast in sunlight.
I want to monopolize.
Authentication unsuccessful.
Will the groom please face the bride while reading?
Look, it's pretty weird for me too.
Ok, we'll try it one more time.
The bride may now read the first portion.
Hello, Nihimi!
Hi, I hope you had fun with the Sims!
I saw that come to Steam too.
I was so excited.
Oh my gosh.
I'm sorry, I'm having to read this with my bride.
It's talking about you.
I want to monopolize.
Authentication successful.
Ok, now we have to say it at the same time.
Hi Naphlings!
You may both enter.
Here we go.
Ready?
Even the very shadow that you cast in sunlight.
I want to monopolize.
Authentication successful.
Oh my god!
I said sunlight, I think I did it.
We finally made it in here.
I can't say I understand Manager Tanaka's bitterness.
Close enough.
Oh wow!
Hello!
Welcome everybody!
I've heard it was beautiful, but I've never been in this suite before.
It's way more extravagant than a regular guest room.
It's perfect for a honeymoon.
I'm playing this game Lifeline.
It's voice activated.
Wait, what are we looking for?
Oh shoot.
Don't just walk around.
There are aliens.
We are on a spaceship and there are aliens.
Attack!
Oh no, no, no!
Oh shoot!
Oh my god!
Right side!
Shoot!
Oh good job.
Right eye!
Shoot!
Left eye!
Run!
Right eye!
Nice!
Left eye!
Oh my god!
Right eye!
No, no, no!
Oh my god!
Left eye!
No!
Right eye!
Run!
Heal?
Actually I need her to heal.
Recover!
Ok, ok, ok.
Right eye!
Oh my gosh, please ma'am.
I'm trying to...Middle eye!
Oh my god, stop shooting the chair, please Rio!
Run!
Run away!
Middle eye!
Right eye!
Left eye!
Nice, nice.
Red eye!
Yes you can!
Don't bullshit me!
Red eye!
Oh, mouth!
Mouth?
Yes you can!
Mouth!
Mouth...
Body!
What do you think?
Mouth?
Body!
Tail?
Tail!
This is what I've been dealing with everybody!
Welcome!
Holy moly!
That was so crazy!
We went into first person view!
I was trying to get out of the...
whatever I was in.
Hold on, I'm looking around.
What do we got here?
Coffee table!
Maybe my aim is bad!
Save point!
Let's go there first.
Run!
Very good Rio!
Peak gaming!
This makes me want to do like...
What was that?
The game where you go...
And you fly and move.
Stand up!
No!
Stop!
She wants me so bad.
She really is kind of obsessed with me.
Lounge table!
That's fine too actually.
Rio always wanting to go to the bed.
Rio and bed, name a better couple.
Cup!
Drink coffee!
I'm so sorry Rio!
I didn't know that you...
You...
This was your game.
You guys watch this!
Bark!
Go!
Walk!
Bark like a dog!
Middle dog?
Or big dog?
Little dog?
Bark like a dog!
Middle dog?
Or big dog?
Okay, so what was the other thing?
We check the coffee table...
Lounge!
Lounge?
What am I missing?
Lounge.
We got it.
Oh my goodness.
It really is honeymoon mode.
Picture.
It looks like a rat.
What is that?
Check photograph.
It looks like a white...
Oh!
You have to see what I see.
Bouquet.
The G-Force.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, so it's got like a little eye...
and there's his arms.
And this is the rat's body.
It's like a white mouse.
Do you see it?
It looks like a little rat.
Wine.
Oh.
Sorry.
Tomato, tomato.
The lid, Patrick.
The lid game.
It's true.
Champagne.
Oh, like you would have drank it anyways.
Food.
No, no, please.
Lounge.
No!
What's happening?
What's going on?
Uh-oh.
Oh no!
Wait, there's going to be a sneak attack.
I know it.
Oh.
I can.
Bathroom.
We're looking.
Okay.
Bathroom.
Zoom.
Okay, just kidding.
Why is there a camera in the toilet?
That's a great question.
Lounge.
Yeah!
Why does she have such trouble with that?
Is it me?
Am I saying it funny?
Okay.
Fruit.
Oh, it was a chip.
After all.
Okay.
Maybe blow that candle out.
Eat fruit.
I do.
Let's see.
Okay.
Second floor.
Wait, can I see it?
Can I...
It won't let me switch the map.
Bedroom?
That's what I said!
Eat peanut butter.
Run.
Oh, I can't talk.
Uh-oh.
We're going to get ambushed maybe?
No, she's just being safe.
I think we're going to get ambushed in here.
What thing?
What is it?
Who is that?
A man.
You called him a thing!
Oh my God!
Wait a second.
I'm human.
Don't shoot.
Hey, I'm sorry.
I thought that an alien had come in here.
I don't have any useful weapons, so the only thing I could do was play dead.
I'm Alan Honda, a researcher.
Can you maybe lower that gun?
I'm human.
I'll admit to being a little weird, but...
Did you just say alien?
Alien.
What else would they be?
What's a laypeople?
What's that?
What is that?
Hello fellow human.
He's nerding out on us.
Why do you have a crop vest?
This guy's outfit.
He's got even a chain.
Like a pocket chain.
Why are you such a jerk?
We just came and saved your butt.
There were monsters downstairs.
You ran into that spider, right?
How did you get away from it?
Please, tell me.
With that.
But it's out of fuel now.
That thing is huge, but it seemed to share similarities with Earth's arthropod, a spider.
So I scared it off with fire.
So it's vulnerable against fire.
Until help arrives, I'm holding up in here.
Earlier, research supervisor Powers sent a rescue signal.
You were literally in danger.
There was a guy downstairs.
So I came to tell the others, but...
Because of that monster spider.
You can't make it to the receiving port?
Bingo!
It's a nasty obstacle.
So, how about it?
Wanna play dead with me?
I'm going.
I have a partner backing me up.
Yeah.
Yes.
What?
What are you going to give me?
Heal?
Shutter key.
Do you really intend to just play dead?
Please refrain from talking to me.
Okay.
Whatever.
This guy is...
Research supervisor really sent for help.
I guess the rescue team is already on the way.
This guy sucks.
Please.
Refrain from talking to me.
Okay.
Oh, it's on that side?
Well, we know where that is.
Okay.
Alright.
Save point?
Okay.
Alright, we went through everything in here I suppose.
So we can go to the save point.
And then go out.
Nice.
I couldn't remember if it was save panel or save point.
Okay.
Nice.
Play tongue twisters?
I don't have that one.
We have another game.
Hold on.
What was it?
We got something else from her.
It was...
We are so needy.
Consultation.
Yeah,
categories.
That's what we got.
Hold on though.
Naomi isn't around.
Oh, I wasn't even saying it.
How are things on Earth?
Oof.
Let's not think about it.
Nice.
The table lamp behind her looks like it has an alien face on it.
How fitting.
What is the manager like?
Okay.
Wait, the guy that was a super jerk to us earlier?
That called us a bimbo?
You see it?
The bogo's been to him.
What do you think of Alan?
That guy sucks.
We can't do a category game.
Okay, so only in motion.
I'm done.
Stop.
Finish.
Okay.
Category game.
Gemini.
Virgo.
Five.
Four.
Capricorn.
Five.
Four.
Scorpio.
Sure.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Boo-boo!
Yeah.
I'm too good at this game.
She looks like she's about to cry.
You're welcome.
Is that the only game we can play?
Only category?
Alright.
Go outside.
Run.
Very good.
Can you romance her?
We have a girlfriend!
We're trying to find our girlfriend Naomi.
Shut her too.
Yeah.
Run.
Okey dokey.
So I guess...
The place that we're trying to... I thought it was behind shutter one that we're trying to get to.
I guess it's shutter four.
She is so impatient.
Please Ryo, I'm working on it.
For once it's safe.
Oh, nevermind.
She's going already.
Can't trust Naomi.
So true.
That's not good.
How big is this place?
We found one!
Empty?
No way.
That was fast.
Maybe find fuel.
That's it?
You give up?
Set yourself.
She was faster than me.
It was so quick.
She was just like, yeah, I'm done now.
What's in here?
Check food unit.
Maybe there is some oil in here, right?
Maybe we can like...
Stick a rag in the oil, right?
Ok, just kidding.
We can make our own molotov.
What else is in here?
Supply unit.
Green box.
That's not what I said.
White box?
Whatever.
I see.
Box.
No, no, no.
What is it?
Supply unit.
She doesn't want to open it up because Solid Snake is in there.
Box.
Supply unit.
Left side.
Left box.
Lift?
There is something in the middle, but I can't tell what it is.
Maybe I'll say just say middle.
What is it?
Middle.
Middle box.
There we go.
How do I turn on the lift?
Here we go.
Power panel on.
Nice.
Gosh, we have all the control.
Ride.
Take lift.
What?
No, no, no.
Ride lift.
Lift.
I know.
Use lift.
Thank you.
Go up.
No, please.
Supply unit.
What did I say to her?
What?
What do you mean?
You are stupid.
Dummy.
Supply unit.
No.
Thank you.
Use lift.
The lift.
OK.
I'm going to try it myself.
I'm not going to say anything.
I'm going to use...Oh here we go.
Lift panel.
OK, here we go.
On.
Sorry.
Oh, sorry.
I think I broke it.
I'm checking.
It has a mind of it's own.
I can't control it.
I'm not pressing anything.
How do I stop it?
Down.
Oh my god.
Oh, sorry.
Maybe I go...down here?
And then over?
I'm trying!
Over?
What does it want me to do?
I don't know.
Operator middle shelf.
I said middle shelf.
I don't know what to do.
Ejector.
I'm trying.
I don't know what...
I'm...there is like...enter?
It doesn't do anything.
There is no enter, you guys.
There is no enter.
I don't know what to do.
Like, enter is not a control that I have.
Spacebar.
I'm on...it's a Playstation 2 game.
I'm on a controller, you guys.
Stop.
Start just does this.
I've already tried mashing buttons, you guys.
I've already tried.
This is X.
This is square.
This is triangle.
Hello.
How do I get this?
Circle is only for talking command.
Down.
As you say, Rio.
As you say.
I don't understand the puzzle.
I feel like I'm missing something.
It won't let me stop.
Stop!
Stop.
I feel like I've tried all options.
Sorry!
Maybe if I go all the way...I don't know.
No, you can't press two buttons at once.
I think if I drive from the middle, it just...it takes me all the way to the top.
From the middle, it takes me all the way to the top, right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I've tried all possible options, I feel.
The guide says you need to use the jam pattern to get it.
What?
What the hell does that mean?
It says you need to jam.
What?
What does a jam mean?
Okay, right?
Oh wait, it like shifted over.
Or am I crazy?
Oh look!
Wait...
Maybe I fixed it.
Hold on, let's...
No...
I don't understand this at all.
I'm so confused.
I'm gonna Google it.
I don't understand.
What is this?
What is this thing called?
A lift puzzle.
Use the pow... wait.
Oh, it's like giving me a hall.
Oh, moon suite?
Okay, we have not gone there yet.
Spider creature?
Oh, I have not gone there yet.
Infirmary?
I have not gone there yet.
Okay.
Sun suite?
Okay, we got there.
Wait a second.
There was supposed to be more things to check in the sun suite.
I think I'm missing a lot of stuff.
Oopsie.
But she didn't want to check the bathroom.
She was telling me to check the bathroom, but she always wanted to not be in there.
Anyway, okay.
Supply unit.
Go... ride the lift.
Left... and up to the top left corner.
Then go right to the top right corner.
Hold down and left together?
Well, check.
Check.
Is it this one?
Incinerate.
Maybe take more of those.
Yay!
We made it.
Okay, get off.
Oh goodness gracious.
Safe point.
This game wants to raise your blood pressure.
I don't have blood.
I have ectoplasm and I feel like I'm bubbling over.
I'm bubbling over.
Okay, nice.
So we don't have to do that again hopefully.
Yeah, number of commands 862.
Ectoplasm pressure, yeah.
Okay, get off the floor Rio.
It's dirty.
Alright, what else did we not check in here?
Mechanical unit.
Yeah.
Unless that was the... Oh no.
No, please God.
Shelf.
No.
Oh, out of order.
Okay, controls inoperable.
Yeah, clearly all of this is.
Okay, I don't think we have to do this again.
So, we...
Data unit.
No.
Maybe a data unit.
Data unit.
I said data!
I said it.
I said data.
Let's see.
Read note.
No.
Notice.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Supply unit lift malfunction.
Refer to the notes below for dealing with the drive system malfunction.
Ah!
It was for that thing.
Oopsie.
What else was there to check?
Check machine.
Yeah.
And then what is that on the ground?
Check cart?
Why don't we take it and ram it into the thing.
Take cart.
Take it.
Why don't we ram it into the spider?
Take cart.
Also, her dress.
Her whole outfit is kind of a mess.
It looks like a joker in the back.
She's got pants, but it's a skirt in the front.
It's just kind of a bizarre waitress outfit.
Move cart.
How do you know?
Alright.
Leave.
Go outside.
What are you talking about?
I'm just trying to figure it out.
Go outside.
I think we're done in here.
Why is it when I tell her to leave, she doesn't know what I'm saying to her?
I think it has trouble with the L's.
I'm like...
We're struggling.
Okay, before we go... I know we have the infirmary on the other side, but before we go there, I want to go back to the Sun Suite.
Sun Suite.
Because it looks like we... Run.
It looks like we might have missed some stuff.
Japanese game after all.
So I have to be like... Run!
Nice.
Okay.
Speak in Japanese.
I wonder...
If I speak in Japanese... I don't think so.
Kitties!
Thanks for the 10 gift and thank you!
Bathroom.
Maybe it's upstairs bathroom.
Okay.
Toilet.
Okay, let's go upstairs.
Upstairs.
The second floor.
Okay.
Run.
The bed.
Okay.
Run.
What happened?
The bed.
Oh my god.
Classic real.
Check washroom.
Oh.
We're just leaving him.
Check flamethrower.
Yeah, this is the same as the one stored in the equipment room.
The fuel gauge is at zero too.
Can we shoot man?
Kill?
Did you say something?
Use gun.
What?
I should have a pillow fight with Alan?
That's stupid.
What?
She's just trying to make him feel better in case he hurt over the little transceiver, you know?
He's like laying there quivering.
He's like, why?
Is she gonna shoot me?
And she's like, what?
No!
Pillow fight!
He's really good at pretending he's dead though.
Check robe.
Isn't he a piece of work?
Yeah.
Check robe.
Not him.
I don't care about him.
Robe.
Stop.
Stop!
Check bed.
Coat?
Instead of...
Coat.
What?
What else is... lab?
That's a... oh.
Lab coat.
And then... paper?
What is that down there?
Paper.
No, no, no.
Stop.
Kick Alan.
Forget it.
There's no point in sitting down.
Bed.
Spore.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
You can tell she's a Vtuber because she doesn't have backseating practice like Chad does.
Okay then.
You guys.
Low kick.
Under bed.
What?
No.
Check under bed.
Check laptop?
Oh it is a laptop.
Excuse me?
What a little...
Take laptop.
The laptop?
I think that means no.
I have a backseating of utter importance.
Go to the sun suite, go to the washroom and check the toilet.
That's what I was about to do.
Go to bathroom.
Oh wait.
No wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Stop!
Go to washroom.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Kick Alan's head.
I tried!
Oh, oh.
Check toilet.
Yep.
This is not a horror game clearly.
Check toilet lid.
Put down toilet lid.
Check behind toilet.
Yippee!
How many of these do I have?
Use toilet.
Toilet paper.
How do I get the lid down?
What do I say?
The feet tapping.
I know she turned into Sonic the Hedgehog.
Check mirror.
Okay.
Close toilet.
Yeah.
Ah!
There we got it.
Spin the gun!
Stop.
Spin the gun.
How do I...
What's the command?
Is it only...
Is it only in a certain thing?
Spin the gun.
Oh, in battle!
Aw man.
We have to wait until we are in battle.
Hold on!
Okay.
I think we are fine for now.
Now we...
Leave.
Go outside.
I can't tell.
There is a little bar.
Oh!
Ghost trio!
KRZ, thank you for the...
Thank you for the five...
Run!
No!
Go outside!
Run!
There is a little bar on the left side of the talking thing.
I can't really tell what it's for.
Gosh.
Infirmary.
Yeah.
Run.
Mic volume?
I see.
I forgot to save again.
It should be fine.
Hopefully.
Hopefully we don't die in here.
Yes.
You never get sick Rio.
Lucky you.
She runs like someone who has never ran before today.
I know.
Death.
Bed?
Alcohol.
Drugs.
Hot nurse.
Nimi nightmare.
I wish I could find hot nurses everywhere.
What else can you find in a...
Bandage.
Why are we playing 20 questions?
Um...
2029 sounds amazing.
So true.
Needles?
One more?
Oxygen?
I did?
No I didn't.
No...
Stethoscope.
What?
Defibrator.
I don't know how to say that word.
Doctor.
Yeah.
Oh right.
Chemicals.
What is this music?
It's slowly turning into peeping music.
Yeah.
What the hell is this?
Cocktail.
The cocktail.
Let me speak!
Gun.
Grenade.
Molotov cocktail.
Yeah!
That's what I said!
Holy cannoli.
This game is so funny.
Oh my goodness.
There is a save point in here.
Let's start with...
Operating table.
It's really dark in here.
It's scary.
Operating table.
Why did she say it like that?
Literally Dora.
I didn't think...
What happened to you?
Check operating table.
Okay.
It's nothing.
You probably don't want to hear from a nice guy like me.
Check bed.
Check the bed.
That's good I guess.
Alright.
Check desk.
Okay.
The episode of Dora where she started trauma dumping was weird.
Isn't that the movie?
That was live action, right?
She was like...
Her family was just like, why are you so strange Dora?
Who are you talking to?
Monitor.
Yes.
PC.
Turn it on.
X-ray.
It's from an employee check up.
But to have someone look inside your body.
Not for me.
Thanks.
I mean you have to sometimes.
What are those?
Cabinet.
There's only anti-nausea medication.
Nausea.
What is that?
The thing in between.
Book.
It's already open.
What do you mean?
Huh?
A Japanese game.
Any suppositories?
I like to get the shiny last guys.
I'm trying to figure out what this thing is in the middle.
Check folders?
No.
Binders?
Yeah.
Check medical book.
I even said book.
There's 50 million of them.
2029 everybody.
There are doctors looking up everything by book.
Check drawer.
Drawer.
Yeah.
We got something.
What is it?
What is that?
Books don't need Wi-Fi to work.
No.
You got me there.
That is so true.
Books don't need Wi-Fi to work.
Wrong button.
This one.
There are a lot of cases.
Let's start with case number one.
Sorry.
I got a little fancy.
Oh yeah.
Turn on PC.
Can't do it.
I won't do it.
Case one.
Rio is kind of unhinged.
You have the card.
Use doctor card.
Right.
Use doctor ID.
Doctor ID.
Use card.
Use ID.
It's not like a code or anything?
Switch.
Open.
Yeah!
Everything is ours.
Smooth operator.
Nice.
Let's go.
Can never have enough of those.
Oh my gosh I keep pressing...
OK.
Case two.
Two drugs.
There's a bunch of pills.
Pills here.
This is the most riveting gameplay.
This is it.
This is the best part.
Oh come on!
Shoot mouth!
Run away!
Shoot head!
Shoot stomach!
Nice.
Shoot head!
Oh wait.
Shoot mouth!
Shoot stomach!
Nice.
That was so smooth.
I forgot to spin the gun!
Sorry guys.
I forgot.
Case two.
How did those get in there?
Why is she putting those things?
No pockets in her stance?
Don't call it that.
Remember.
Yell it next time guys.
I'll get it.
Case three.
Just yell.
Just yell next time.
Just be like spin gun!
Spin gun!
You can spam it.
I give you permission.
I give you permission to spam.
I'll try to look over.
That was too fast.
You can turn on the PC with your controller.
Like how you unlock doors.
Really?
Thank you Tom.
I will turn it on.
What's that?
Ointment.
Wait there is something right there.
That looks like alcohol.
Whiskey.
I like the way she looks at the camera.
Chug it.
Chug chug chug.
Yeah.
I think so.
I think it will do a fantastic job.
I think that's what they are meant to do.
Uh oh.
This isn't a movie.
I mean...
Animals attack people.
And those live on earth.
What do you mean?
It's not a movie.
It's a video game.
Thank you.
Rio.
People attack people.
Exactly.
Rio, you are so silly girl.
You are so silly.
What was it?
Wait.
Check desk.
I can't with her.
She is so silly.
Okay, so the PC.
I got it.
Thank you.
Sorry my mouse is all stuffed up.
Oh we unlocked the sexy pose.
Oh no.
Look at the membership.
Oh my gosh.
No wonder she wouldn't do it before.
We just never had it unlocked.
Sexy pose.
No.
No absolutely not ma'am.
Sexy pose.
Go.
Leave.
Go outside.
Yes.
Stop.
Sexy pose.
Oh my god.
Zoom.
Sexy...
Sexy pose.
Hold on.
Order of operations.
Sexy pose.
Zoom.
Okay we have two other cases we can check.
Case four.
Okay.
It is.
It is Marine.
It really is.
Where are you?
That's Marine pose.
Now you can disengage the locks.
Marines.
Oh no.
Okay.
It's only one.
We're good.
Spin gun.
Mouth.
Stomach.
Head.
Oh there is more than one.
Oh my god.
Stomach.
No.
Please.
Stomach.
Oh my god.
Please.
Run away.
I already spin the gun you guys.
Stomach.
Mouth.
There we go.
Run.
In her mouth.
Oh my
god.
Please.
In her mouth.
No.
Mouth!
Run!
Oh my gosh.
Mouth!
Dodge!
Head!
Stomach!
Mouth!
I mean, head!
Run!
Kick!
Low kick!
Run!
Guys!
Stomach!
Run!
Not over him!
Stomach!
OK, run!
In her mouth!
Dodge!
Oh,
says you!
Says you, Rio!
Your freaking aim!
In her mouth.
My goodness.
Oh my gosh.
I think you can only say tongue when the tongue is out, but the timing is so difficult.
Thank you for not saying number 2 in her mouth.
Case 5.
In whose mouth?
Oh my goodness.
You guys are terrible.
You are all terrible, you know that?
Stinky!
I need the throat tea.
Nice.
That should be maybe the fourth one.
OK.
Have Rio take the monster out to dinner before you shoot it in her mouth.
It was...no.
It was here.
Oh, we need one more for the second fourth one.
Nice.
And we have 4 heal capsules.
I feel like we should use one, but...
She's just walking around.
Did you guys see the gun spin?
No?
She did it twice.
Nice!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Alright.
What's the place called?
Save point.
You're the one who yelled sex and Rio ran to the bed.
OK, saying I yelled sex is a bit of a...
I think that's a bit of a drama adaptation, don't you think?
I think that's a bit...
I said...
I didn't demand anything.
Look, she's traumatized.
Well guys, I think I'm gonna end it here actually.
Oh my goodness, it's already been 4 hours.
4 hours of Lifeline.
Goodness gracious this game.
I feel...
I don't know how I stood it for this long.
But this has been a lot of fun.
Please play for 37 hours.
No, please.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you!
Spank!
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Different kind of rage game.
For real.
Holy moly.
But this game is so silly.
The Marine pose is funny because Senchou actually played the JP version of this years ago.
No way!
Seriously?
Sexy pose, baby.
Sexy pose!
Thanks so much, Minto.
She looks like she's in like a psych ward.
It's OK.
You're alright, Ryo.
You're OK.
Thanks for the one stream.
Thank you!
I had a lot of fun.
Tomorrow's stream is a bit of a different case.
Doki and I are going to be like...
We're co-casting this tournament.
It's like a MOBA.
But Minecraft.
It's kind of weird.
So tomorrow is going to be a little bit different.
I'm probably not going to be able to talk with chat much.
I might do a stream...
I don't know.
Oh no, but I want to watch the birthday live.
I'll see you Sunday if not.
Or if you can't watch Sunday.
I'll see you Monday.
Can you hear me?
Oh gosh, Ryo is really losing it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's going to be a little weird.
I'm not quite sure how to think of it either.
But it should be fun, I think.
But this was a lot of fun too.
And thank you guys for watching and sticking around and hanging out with me.
Thank you, Ryo!
Thank you.
Oh gosh, she's so rude.
Thank you!
No.
Who's cat is this?
Otsumito everyone!
Thank you!